hey guys I'm Ryan writes I'm brandy
Frank today we're gonna check out the
video ten most Awkward sex scenes and
movies
I'm sure I can relate to this video
let's check it out say my name [__]
nearly all actors will tell you that sex
scenes are hands down the most awkward
to film entirely lacking the romance
they're supposed to continue in both the
real world and in movies sexuality has
the ability to provoke reactions and
just about anyone but some scenes just
make us feel really really awful honor
if that feeling here are screenrant's 10
most painfully awkward sex scenes and
movies that's the second time I've heard
that
what is the [__] on a pedestal thing
the 40 year old virgin
Steve Carell is no stranger to the
concept of awkwardness he made a name
for himself as Michael Scott from the
office arguably the most awkward
character on television this ability to
earn sympathy and laughs translates
beautifully into this trainwreck of a
sex scene from the 40 year old virgin
it's because of how excited he is at the
prospect of knocking boots but a young
Carell neglects to mention to his date
that he is insanely ticklish and she
finds out the hard way needless to say
she isn't too happy about her broken
nose and goes on to berate him crushing
his self-esteem in the process is the
cringe-worthy encounter sparse Karl's
character for a life leaving him a
virgin until the age of 40 Watchmen not
even sack Snyder's perfect lighting can
disguise her awkward action between
Malin Akerman and Patrick Wilson in this
scene from 2009 s watch while everyone
loves the song hallelujah it's hard to
know just what to make of the two actors
chemistry as they offer the ship through
the control room of night owls aircraft
Wilson's character is shot to be able to
perform an anchorman plays up on the
other end of the spectrum Watchmen
opened up in more theaters around the
world than any other r-rated movie at
the time so it's safe to say that plenty
of audiences caught it on the big screen
stepbrothers catching your parents in
the act is one of the most traumatic
things a movie or TV child can
experience but stepbrothers takes that
scenario just a little bit further
during the family's Christmas dinner
john c reilly and kathryn hahn sneak
away for a quickie things quickly spiral
out of control when the couple burst
through a door in the dining room and
find themselves front and center during
the family's meal twice between hans
raucous rendition of god rest ye merry
gentlemen and Riley's makeshift excuses
no one grows suspicious
Hanz husband even requests that his wife
grab him a beer issue grab me a beer the
audience sits in a state of perpetual
anxiety but the thought that the lovers
could be caught at any second making the
scene both entertaining and horrify
[Music]
world police despite being offered a
sequel Team America creators Matt Stone
and Trey Parker vowed to never work with
puppets again but not before creating
one of the most surprising and memorable
sex scenes of all time stone and Parker
set out to choreograph a display so
over-the-top it would distract the
censors from the rest of the movies
crude humor and violence when it came to
determining the overall rating of the
movie requiring 9 edits a version of the
original scene was included in the
theatrical release with the full and
uncut scene available in the Unrated
version at the insistence of Matt stop
perhaps assuming that all puppet movies
are kid-friendly Team America was
mistakenly touted as a movie for all
ages in some parts of Europe presumably
before anyone there actually watched a
new American pop it's the definitive
coming-of-age story focused around
losing your virginity before graduation
American Pie dealt with nearly every
insecurity and misconception teams have
to deal with when it comes to sex when
one of Jim Levenstein so-called
experienced friends compares women to
apple pie
Jim is determined to do some kitchen
research so when his mom leaves him a
freshly baked apple pie he decides to
get in some practice for fear of seeming
amateurish with his high-school crush it
doesn't take long for the scene to get
seriously awkward music alone is enough
to make audiences want to jump out of
their skin Jim is caught with his pants
down when his dad returns to find his
son making love to the destiny
see cemented American Pie is one of the
raunchiest commies of the 90s a
designation that still holds up today a
night at the Roxbury Molly Shannon and
Will Farrell literally and
metaphorically get down to business in
this entry from a night at the Roxbury
these two don't disappoint and their
ability to make audiences feel painfully
awkward after gaining major exposure on
Saturday Night Live the hilarious life a
brother Steven doug butabi were expanded
into an endlessly quotable full-length
feature film part of the viewers pain
comes from Shannon's character so
obviously using her sexuality to
manipulate ferrell yet he hardly
protests as she tricks him into merging
their family companies and proposing all
in one fell swoop
the other part comes from Shannon's love
of furniture closely mirroring a
real-life fetish called object sexuality
in which people become attracted to
inanimate objects she yells out all of
her favorite pieces kind of makes us
wonder if Ferrell actually needs to be
there at all bad teacher filmed after
their very public real-life breakup
Cameron Diaz and Justin Timberlake turn
up the awkward factor for this offering
from 2011's bad teacher after spending
months luring the hunky new teacher away
from a rival at school
Diaz's character finally gets her chance
in bed with Timberlake's heartthrob
Scott Delacorte the tryst quickly goes
downhill as Diaz realizes this might not
be the night of her dreams
during the awkward frenzy she alternates
between confusion and boredom to make
matters worse Scott's girlfriend hears
the whole thing leading her to believe
the affair was a lot sexier than an
action was thankfully for Diaz and the
audience it's over almost as quickly as
I began but not before Scott gives Diaz
one last oblivious kiss on the forehead
much to her disgust this scene is proof
that beautiful people don't always make
beautiful of McGregor no the director of
this Saturday Night Live spin-off didn't
hold back when it came to McGregor's
most memorable sexy
starting off as a throwback to the
cheesy love scenes of the 1980s the
sequence gets progressively weirder with
every second when the music abruptly
stops the Cena stripped of all modesty
[Laughter]
reveals the painfully awkward reality of
this hero's idea of romance SNL alumni
will for tan Kristen Wiig carry it
perfectly making the scene as hilarious
as it is unpleasant the scene was filmed
on wigs birthday and while her body
language comes off as passionate she's
actually trying to avoid the very real
sweat pouring off after Costa how's that
for happy birthday
[Music]
demolition man what do car washes and
futuristic madman may have in common
they're both without contact concept
that Sylvester Stallone fumbles with the
1993's demolition after Sandra Bullock
drops in science about the link between
violence and arousal she propositioned
[__] which seems to confuse him more
than anything
since fluid transfers are banned in the
future San Angeles the characters get
down with the use of what can only be
described as sex homes making faces like
he's trying to solve a difficult math
problem Stallone delivers his most
awkward performance to date and then
cruises infamous early experiences with
adult films well it does your best to
keep the secrets believable but the
startling edits and quick cuts love both
theme and the Tim the tool man Taylor SP
noises emanating from Stallone are
unsettling enough to get under almost
anyone's skin
the meaning of life possibly the least
sexy depiction of sex on our list is
this educational opportunity courtesy of
the Monty Python classic the meaning of
life they deem showing up at school
naked as nightmare-inducing for men but
it's just another day on the job for
John Cleese who plays an eccentric
teacher hell-bent on teaching his pupils
about the birds and the bees he and his
wife perform a demonstration for the
group of students alternating between
bickering with the spouse and
disciplining the onlookers and cleans
throws out words like intercourse and
coitus making this scene feel like the
world's most awkward biology class the
Monty Python troupe are known for being
tongue-in-cheek
this kid is definitely one of their most
outlandish however scientifically
accurate it may be that's our list of
the 10 most cringe-worthy sex scenes in
movies did we miss any scenes and you
feel painfully awkward to watch let us
know about them in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for more videos like this one
thanks Rain Man you guys Rock Screen
Rant you guys rock you know people who
thought about that Watchmen sex scene as
if it's like this really awkward scene
and I thought it was like intentionally
funny when she's orgasm and she presses
the button and then the flame comes out
like it's supposed to be funny but
everyone treats it like oh it was just
uncomfortable to watch and it was
awkward ah I don't know I think that was
adorable I think it was just because
they were so different like she's like
all like uh and he's like mmm
then he gained weight for the role to
here's a little heavier you know he's
usually pretty cut wasn't it Patrick
Wilson yeah he's usually pretty good in
that movie he was kind of fat you know
it was kinda like my body it's like it's
like imagining watching Veronica and I
having sex it's like wow ronk is so hot
wish she had a better looking partner
though you know what I mean no you don't
know what I mean you're been with a fat
guy and ain't it ain't easy oh I would
have liked the list where it was like
it's supposed to be sexy and stuff but
yeah sexy it's one thing because if it's
intentionally awkward and uncomfortable
that's one thing but if it's like these
really work yeah a lot of these are like
intended to be funny and stuff like the
stepbrothers one especially the American
Pie one but it's interesting looking
back on some of these films cuz like
American Pie of such a classic scenes
dude [__] up high and it was so
memorable yeah really it's such a it's
such a sexual scene but your life it
just stands out in your brain and it
it's it's called American pine they made
four of those and then a bunch of
straight-to-dvd movies Jason Biggs
[__] the PI created history created
history the tea America World Police sex
scene I saw an interview with the
creators where they made that sex scene
a million times worse like he was
[__] on her face and stuff so that
way the sensor boards would wait yeah
they would say cut back on it and Wilma
will give you an R rating right actually
my dad got me a puppet like a little
marionette like little guy when I was in
third grade I don't know whatever
happened to that was it who's the puppet
of your dad no it was like a little
Mexican that's why you like little
Mexicans yeah and like a sombrero and
everything did he dump like this
did he have a voice box that you push a
button man you need an egg Thank You USA
sorry that's my mentioned aggression
that's how I think I really like the bad
teachers it is great because it was such
a build-up to them having a sex scene
and like okay these guys dated in real
life they're both really sexy
I love how Justin Timberlake was willing
to make an ass out of themselves really
whenever a celebrity who's like has a
certain image is willing to like
completely destroy that image I think
it's [__] awesome and I gave major
kudos to Justin Timberlake for doing
that but I kind of wish we got a real
sex scene from them
no I think it was awesome how it was I
love the looks on her face too like oh
great no but I would love to see you
would you have enjoyed it oh really
that's how he makes love Veronica every
it's all about pleasing me the dry
humping I don't like actual genitals
touching it's like she's out of that I
want to talk about demolition man real
fast because I want talking about
Sylvester Stallone Stallone
I heard he did a porno I ended up
finding that poor dude
I found that wanna and it was really
awkward to watch it was like what
because it was like how he looked in the
first Rocky uh-huh you know where he's
not like Stallone super cut guy yeah
he's like his reason will be you know
strong it was really weird to watch like
Stallone [__] a girl I like seen his
dick and stuff you know you could see
Stallone's dick
dude dude dude that's my still on here
just makes random noises really yeah you
like that [__] really now these are
some classic memorable moments actually
right here you know like I like seeing
these kind of lists because they remind
you of like oh yeah that film did that
cuz there's so many [__] films
I love channels like this that are
willing to go out of their way and like
spend a long time so much time put into
these videos it's almost as much work as
I put into this channel sit down
move my three lights over just slide
them over hit record
watch a video it's hard it's really
really hard work I don't get why people
bag on reactors these days because this
is the hardest job you can do thousands
of views that is definitely earned thank
you guys thank you anyway guys thanks
for tuning in to the channel if you're
new to it you can subscribe you the real
rejects you can check out a pretty
prices Channel and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
periscope
Jarrid Anthony as soon see on hey real
rejects may I get a shout out I first
discovered your channel when I saw your
Man of Steel review back in 2013 I then
saw a lot of your movie reviews and
trailer reactions since then then when I
was able to get a YouTube account
I immediately subscribe to your channel
first as it is my favorite of all the
other reaction channels your channel is
awesome in the humor it's really
entertaining get as many subscribers as
you can and as you say more subscribers
equals more product placement I will
always watch your channel and watch
every new video that comes out until I
die good luck and keep up the good work
seriously thank you so much man it means
a lot that you'd say all those kind
things it makes me feel warm and fuzzy
on the inside and just so you know you
look young so I want to give you some
fatherly advice here whatever happens
whatever happens there's always a way to
convince them of what you want I can't
tell you exactly what that means but
there's this thing called sexual
intercourse sometimes the woman's not
gonna want something but there's always
a way there keyphrase manipulate
manipulate a woman into doing what you
want to do
every woman I've ever had sex with it
always wants anal sex they think they
don't until they talk to me then they
want it threesomes DPS double
penetration
yeah I've been able to arrange all kinds
of insane [__] so Jared just now the
word manipulate will become your best
friend
thank you I'm Ryan right